think bigger with your business at some
point you have to realize that you're
good at what you do and you deserve a
better life for yourself and that counts
from thinking and acting bigger hi I'm
Evan Carmichael I believe that hungry
entrepreneurs deserve help and on the
weekend I was at a baseball game with my
buddy John and we're enjoying the game
unfortunately Jays laws again such a
disappointing season anyway halfway
through the game John stops me in the
ass I've and I'd like to get your
opinion on something and he talks about
this deal that he's potentially working
on with this guy who he really wants and
press it's a it's a big angel investor
he's had a lot of success in business
and he wants John's advice on a deal
that's coming in and John sinking will
do I go in as a consultant and ask for a
fee or do I try to make myself a part of
this project even though it's a smaller
project than he normally does and yes
what would you do Evan if he if it were
you and I told them I hate being a
consultant it's such a small game you're
just trading your time for money you
maybe make a couple thousand dollars
from this deal but it's such a small
game from the deal that he's gonna be
making here from that company when he's
buying how much is he going to make off
of it not only just this year but
ongoing and he's leveraging your ideas
and your expertise so you can make a
couple thousand dollars while he makes
it big you've got to think bigger you've
got to play the bigger game this is even
a small deal for my friend and I told
them if I were you I'd give the advice
for free let them know listen this is a
small deal for me I usually look at
deals that are three three times the
size or whatever it is but I want to
help you out and I do this all the time
for most entrepreneurs I give advice for
free and what it does here with my
friend jon is it builds a better
relationship with that investor because
if he just sells his services for a
couple thousand dollars then he'll
always be thought of as an expert but as
a service provider you're his supplier
instead of being his partner where you
should be his partner and bringing him
to a bigger game if he's got the money
and you've got the expertise you should
combine up take on a much bigger deal
and
share in the profits that's thinking
bigger that's playing the bigger game
and we all do this with our business we
play small we're constantly on this
treadmill running running running and
not really moving anywhere to level up
you've got to think bigger you've got to
play that bigger game and get yourself
in on the deals instead of just being a
supplier and I know it's hard I know
it's hard I know what you're thinking
you know I've got bills to pay I need to
put food on the table and if you're in
survival mode right now if you haven't
gotten to the point where you're making
enough money to pay the bills then find
feed yourself the first part is getting
to survival right you have to make sure
you're still around so take the
consulting gig but as you grow once you
pass that survival point you need to
think bigger you got to take more risks
you got to go after the bigger deals
stop settling for life that's less than
you deserve I hope you guys enjoyed for
those of you watching if you liked it
please give it a thumbs up and I'd love
to hear you have to think I always loved
those comments makes my mornings if you
want to leave a comment about this video
or your question for your own business
feel free to leave it in the comments
section below I really do always read
those and love seem to come in so thank
you keep thinking big and i'll see you
on the next episode
I